Speaker 1: Reactionary populism. That's the name
we should be using for this sort of newish right
wing that some call Trumpism. Our friend Aaron
Rupert, I believe, with a guest writer named
November Laski, has a nice piece on his substack
called Elon Musk's Reactionary Populism. I want
to zoom out from Elon Musk a little bit and
just kind of give you a foundation to think
about this movement, because we it's very easy and
popular now to say MAGA isn't conservative. Jair
Bolsonaro is not a conservative. These are we're
not recognizing traditional conservatism in this
new movement. What is it? Reactionary. Populist,
I believe, is something that encapsulates a
reactionary. Populism is a political ideology
characterized by populist rhetoric and using
populist rhetoric for the people. Right.
That's what we're talking about when we say
populist rhetoric. Populist rhetoric to oppose
progressive social and progressive political
change. So it often will involve rejecting
established political institutions, a defense of
traditional values and ways of life. But under the
rhetoric, because remember, populism is a rhetoric
rather than a set of policy ideas, using the
rhetoric of populism for your opposition, we're
against this trans stuff. Because of what's best
for the average person and the people. The average
girl playing sports, the trans stuff is bad for
the. So they use populist rhetoric to oppose
relatively standard at this point, quite
frankly, progressive political and social
change. They focus on nostalgia for a past that
may not even have existed. That's an important
thing to understand. They refuse to acknowledge
and address the challenges that we have today
through this nostalgic focus on a past, past that
may or may not have been real. They will resist
the progressive social and political change which
can actually hinder progress and hinder social
mobility. In many cases, they reject established
political institutions, which will often lead them
to ignore the rule of law. That's sounding pretty
familiar when we think about Donald Trump and MAGA
Trumpism. They will defend traditional values
and ways of life, but not with the traditional
conservative rhetoric. They will defend it with
populist sounding rhetoric which can trick people.
And this is how some left wingers fall prey and
victim to right wing populist rhetoric. They will
often promote nativist and protectionist policies
like around immigration. Justifying it by saying
This is what's good for the people. And of course,
in so doing, they'll harm global trade. They'll
destroy alliances with other countries, as we
saw under Trump. They will resist globalization
generally. They will resist immigration. They
will resist social diversity, all using the
pseudo populist rhetoric of what's best for the
people. And as we saw during the COVID pandemic,
the reactionary populists will often reject
evidence and expertize. And that can undermine
public policy. It can undermine decision making.
It can undermine the country coming together to
actually deal with issues. Perfectly describes
what happened thanks to the MAGA right under
during the COVID pandemic under Donald Trump. The
reality, of course, is that while the reactionary
populists will use rhetoric that sounds like maybe
it's sort of left wing, it's not in the sense that
this reactionary populist movement is associated
with the far right, far right political movements,
extremists, etc., and it will all be under the
guise of we are under threat. They will use fear.
We are under threat. It's a political ideology
rooted in reactionary right wing conservatism
and a nationalist worldview. But it has been sort
of passed through a populist rhetoric filter. So
examples include Trump, of course, the Hungarian
prime minister, Viktor Orban, French politician,
Marine Le Pen. Brazilian president, former
president Jair Bolsonaro. These are leaders
whose supporters will often espouse populist
sounding rhetoric, but they oppose progressive
political change. They oppose progressive
social change. They appeal to a nostalgia
that may not exist. And they at the end of the
day, when you get to policy, which you don't
always get to with the reactionary populists,
they promote nativist policy, protectionist
policy and reactionary policy. I think that's as
good a name as any reactionary populism. Let me
know your thoughts. Check out Aaron and Noah's
piece and we'll follow up about this again.